next bill minute Aglio tells the story
of an explosion and fire in 1947 that
killed hundreds of people in Texas City
the source of the explosion was a plant
where ammonium nitrate was being
converted for use as fertilizer by
war-torn European countries this is a
little under an hour and a half
thank you very much for coming out on a
cooled Austin night very very generous
EU to come spend some time with me
I'm guessing even before it I began that
there are a lot of people here tonight
and know more about the Texas City
disaster than I do and I'm looking
forward to hearing your stories and I
bet a lot of the folks here will find
their stories maybe more fascinating
than what I wrote in this book let me
just read a little bit and hopefully set
the table for what the story is about
I'm gonna start reading a little bit
into the book about a Catholic priest
who central to my story he's one of the
heroes of the book and in the weeks
building up to the Texas City disaster
in 1947 is very courageous brave priest
who I think really defined the word
populist and he was trying to correct
some wrongs in Texas city began having
very unsettling visions very prophetic
visions and you know to his closest
friends it was very eerie a very ominous
his family members couldn't really
understand what was happening to him and
he was literally wasting away before
people's eyes in all of this kind of
bills up to a moment in April on a very
very beautiful a day a very beautiful
spring day in April and 47 the
premonitions have reached such a point
that the the priest knows that
something's going to happen this day and
maybe even the next few minutes I'll
just begin here it's 8:45 a.m. as he
runs he
as longshoremen Carrie Johnson briskly
walking in the other direction
Johnson stares at roach and thinks that
he's a good man about the only damned
white man you could seriously trust in
Texas City in a way that he hadn't ever
talked with anyone about Johnson had
come to love father Roach the priest has
passed Johnson now scrambling onto the
wharf feeling the walls of heat and
aiming for a well-dressed man who's
staring into the ceaseless banks of
smoke heaving from deep inside the
superheated freighter there are men
screaming something from the gunmetal
gray deck railings of the ground come
their words being swallowed by the
roaring painful cracking noises
ricocheting deep inside the ships holes
father Roach watches as the ship's decks
suddenly swells it rises like a pregnant
mass covered by hissing wood and hot
steel the water in the bay is beginning
to churn frothing as if it is being
beaten Roach bolts to mike mckowski side
and for a second the most important
person in Texas City the man who runs
the company and the waterfront pulls his
attention from the spreading commotion
the cresting noise and the urgent voices
on the pier dozens of firemen are racing
into the smoke six firemen are futile e
wrestling with a hose it looks as if
they are spraying steam instead of water
the inferno blasts are so intense that
is the water roars out of the hose it is
instantly vaporized mckisco turns and
stares at the wild-eyed priest now
tarpaulin zuv smoker speeding and
flooding across the sixty foot wide deck
of the big ship pooling in corners they
spin into thick masses and soar straight
into the sky
there was a nauseating chemical stench
sailors are yelling in French and
disappearing amid the billows frantic
longshoremen suddenly comes shoving out
of a north-facing wall of black haze now
there are 28 firemen facing the ship all
of them desperately trying to unroll the
hoses they inch toward the huge rattling
freighter while dozens of sailors and
dock workers scramble down ropes and
gangplanks and flee in the opposite
direction on the rim of the docks the
wide I children in the crowd of 500
onlookers are hurrying clapping with
each new commotion with each new cloud
that Rockets up spreads out over the bay
like
painting by Matisse and then zooms to
the Gulf of Mexico it is the most vivid
beautiful thing they have ever seen over
his shoulder just after 9 a.m.
Carrie Johnson can hear father Roach
screaming roaches voices rising out of
the babble Rocha wonders of Mackesy I
can even hear him whether macheska wants
to hear him overhead two airplanes are
banking and turning into the deepest
part of the chemical fog Roach is still
shouting move that damn ship father
William Francis Roach had always felt
that wildly wickedly disparate things
and people improbably converged on Texas
City drag that ship into the bay right
now move the ship into open water Roach
like the hundreds of people who have
crowded near the vessel can hardly see
the 7,200 ton ship looks as if it's
gasping for breath the deck planks are
bending horribly and long rusted nails
are shooting straight up into the air
suddenly there is a long fast series of
sharp cracking noises like machine gun
blasts coming from below decks roaches
begging please move the damn ship you
can see that the Gulf of Mexico is
bubbling and it is if as it is something
from his delirious dreams the sea is now
boiling it's got a story interrupt us
I'll leave you right there but the one
thing that I learned about Texas City
and I think there's a lot of debate
about what happened there what in what
some people call the greatest industrial
disaster in the most industrialized
nation in the history of mankind one
thing that I think a lot of people agree
upon is that it took a lot of trains
moving from different stations to
converge for this than to occur
you know looking back at what happened
at 9/11 that day and a lot of stories
written about how if the weather had
been a little bit different just many
millions of little things have been
different maybe 9/11 as we know it
wouldn't have occurred the same rules
apply in Texas City what makes this
story I think a little bit different is
that in my estimation this is the least
known and least appreciated in in one
sense of the word disaster in American
history an enormous loss of life
somewhere around 600 confirmed the
possibility of being many more dead as
many as 5000 injured in today's dollars
around five four point five billion
dollars in damage an entire fire
department wiped off the face of the
earth in fact the greatest American fire
department tragedy prior to 9/11 just
incredibly significant amount of ripple
effect from this story and I began to
wonder and I'm sure some somebody Alaska
later why I began writing this story let
me skip ahead when I was into the story
I began wondering with amazement why we
hadn't heard more about the Texas City
disaster why it wasn't honored
appreciated studied and I think I came
you know upon a two-fold answer that's
something to do with the first and
foremost the people who live in Texas
City who lived there there and lived
there now extraordinary hard-working
folks who really put their shoulder to
the wheel and in a very quiet anonymous
ways people who have very little time
for melancholy they wake up in the
morning go to work and and do really
hard work if any of you have been to
Texas City and again I'm guessing that
some of you have been or are from there
it's a essentially a factory town it's a
refinery a driven community and
dominated by the petrochemical and the
energy industry
set aside any feelings you have about
what that means politically speaking
environmentally speaking at the very
bottom line level it means hard work and
dangerous work in in Texas City I found
over and over again very curiously I
thought initially people would come to
me and say why are you writing this
story it's either not that important or
we just don't want the attention we
don't want to draw attention to
ourselves and I went ahead and wrote the
book you know I beg to differ
and hopefully I came to the store it and
you'll be the judge with some measure of
you know ever ongoing respect for the
fact that people not only confronted an
apocalyptic moment on earth but then
lived it in a way to almost honor it by
not drawing attention to it if that
makes sense
almost aggressively so sort of a pre
media age you know CNN wasn't there
cameras weren't present and people
didn't seek that out let nor they do
they do today
so a lot of forms of courage and bravery
were exhibited in Texas City and sort of
it when the dust settles or settled that
was a certainly one aspect of bravery
something else that really occurred to
me as I was wrapping up the book and
working with my wonderful research team
I see one there Mike Smith raise your
hand Mike would you if you don't mind
and of Jordans here I don't know if
she's here as well Jordan Smith but Mike
and Jordan Smith to veer off the track a
little bit are among the finest
researchers in America
had the benefit of working with them in
a biography that I did of President Bush
and neither of these books would have
been done without their expert work so
thanks one thing that that emerged real
quickly as well as we were working on
this book together
you know 9/11 occurred and it set in
motion some very specific things that
happened to me that are that are
probably less interesting that I think
that the bigger picture the bigger
picture parallels you know inside her
baseball my editors took a look and what
had happened and said my gosh you've
written a story about a disaster that
occurred in 1947 will anybody even care
anymore
and I said to them what I think is true
that the same lessons in human courage
and bravery those manifest instances
when people you know reach deep inside
of themselves when confronted with
something awful those kind of universal
tales that we look for in human nature
were there in Texas City and they were
they were hidden and they were quiet and
therefore always and forever deserve to
be remembered
so I differed a little bit with my
publishers and editors about you know
the worth of this story in some way the
editors and publishers believed in the
book but I think they blinked a little
bit if I may say so and but then we
rolled forward and and continue the book
the parallels were extraordinary there
are two planes that struck the World
Trade Center there were two planes you
know shot out of the sky over Texas City
that awful day there were initial
thoughts that terrorists had invaded the
United States or had launched an attack
and were attacking kind of the the
industrial underbelly of the United
States in this vulnerable place the very
essence of the story revolves around a
magical brilliant and in an awful
compound called ammonium nitrate that
too has a parallel to 9/11 in the first
attack on the World Trade Center in 1993
terrorists employed ammonium nitrate to
try to topple the World Trade Center in
93 ammonium nitrate is what blew up in
Texas
and devastate of the town and changed
things forever for thousands and
thousands of people not only in Texas
City but across America ammonium nitrate
was used by Timothy McVeigh it's
probably where it's most commonly known
used by Timothy McVeigh in his horrible
attack on the Federal Building in
Oklahoma City and remember this is
decades after people knew about the
abilities the awful abilities of
ammonium nitrate in 1947 you know
working on this book and and this story
there was a danger of almost
disappearing down a rabbit hole there
was just so many entry points and exit
points for the story and fortunately
with the help of good researchers great
researchers we tried to keep the story
focused one of the things where I think
I was most in danger one of the areas
where I was most in danger of
disappearing forever into the writing
cave was exploring ammonium nitrate I
suppose I went into journalism for the
reason a lot of journalists they weren't
very good at math or science so stuck to
the word side of school and tried to
learn you know what ammonium nitrate was
and most estimations are that it is just
one of the most fabulous and brilliant
chemical compounds to be perfected by
man at the turn of the the dawn of the
20th century scientists came to a very
real belief that we on planet earth were
running out of food that the population
on planet Earth was just growing
exponentially and we wouldn't have the
ability to to feed ourselves that a
clarion call went out to the brilliant
scientists of the day to retreat into
the labs and come up with something come
up with a solution and a brilliant Nobel
prize-winning German chemist came out of
his lab announcing that he had
essentially perfected and
it wanted to introduce a substance a
perfected version of ammonium nitrate
that would be the greatest fertilizer in
in mankind's history and with some
debate and argument you could actually
suggest that that's true people have
told me farmers have told me you throw
the stuff on the ground and crops spring
forth you know later that day it's it's
an exaggeration but it's good stuff and
millions and millions of people around
the world and as I say in the book are
addicted to it in the sense that we
wouldn't have crops growing in such
great abundance without this chemical
that's the good side there's a there's a
bad side
there's several bad sides to that
actually the primary bad side is an
ammonium nitrate as it was being
developed had this genus like ability to
bring you know great joy and great
sorrow all at once as he was developing
it as a fertilizer it was also being
developed virtually the same substance
being developed as an as an incredible
explosive something that could be used
in the mom making plants during World
War one and especially during World War
two and it was produced and produced in
great tonnage around the world for that
latter use the story to me I mentioned
earlier the my belief that there are a
lot of trains that had to leave the
station all around the the world in fact
to bring us to a spring morning in April
in 1947 in a small town 15,000 people on
the and the the the coast of Texas
geopolitical forces such as they are
suggested that during World War two we
needed a lot of ammonium nitrate for
bombs for making bombs after World War
two ended the hot war ended the Cold War
began in the White House President
Truman sent down orders essentially that
we needed to reseed the fields of Europe
and feed the bellies of
Europeans and win their hearts and minds
and keep them away from the the sway the
tug of communism and the the rising
specter if you will of the Soviet Union
Texas City which had helped to win the
war by by providing all the the fuel and
the petrochemicals that we would need to
win the war dominated by you know what
some folks used to call Rosie the
riveters a lot of hard-working women who
worked in defense plants and then
repopulated after the war by veterans
would come back home after surviving
enormous peril overseas came to work in
this boomtown called Texas City to
process transport ammonium nitrate to
begin winning that other war the Cold
War the folks in Texas City you know
that I met didn't dwell on this at that
time they I don't think sat around the
refinery on their brakes and talked
about the Welling specter of communism
or the the dawning age of the Cold War
they had had work to do they had to
punch the clock that to make sure their
kids got to school the town was so
booming and overcrowded with people
jockeying for these blue-collar refinery
jobs at school was split into twin ships
they were so crowded that they had to
separate essentially the student body at
a young age into two groups the kids who
came in in the afternoon and the kids
who came in in the morning a very
important point in terms of convergence
it meant that on a beautiful spring
morning to repeat myself there were a
lot of children who weren't in school
out of necessity because Texas City was
so booming because somewhere all the way
up the chain in the White House somebody
had deemed it important to produce
ammonium nitrate and win that war in
Europe it you could you know connect the
dots in some way it's like a series of
dominoes I suppose a click and clack and
fall over because of decisions made in
the White House children in some way
weren't in school in Texas City the
President had ordered ammonium nitrate
to be produced
massive quantities to help win that cold
war it resulted in work in Texas City it
resulted in people moving in Texas City
resulted in Texas City being so crowded
that children were told come to the
afternoon session as opposed to the
morning session and children being
children I've got two of my own saw
something welling up just like father
Roche had seen welling up on the
waterfront that morning so beautiful
plumes of smoke tangerine colored smoke
unlike anything they had ever seen even
far beyond the qualities of a really
good firework show something really
magnetic and kids almost like you know
the Pied Piper they began riding their
bikes down their little homemade
scooters holding hands walking down to
the waterfront sometimes going with
their parents they wanted to see the
fires see the smoke and again I'm
probably a guilty as charged of
connecting too many dots but to me there
really was a cause-and-effect giant
geopolitical forces were whirling around
way above the cloud line way outside the
the real realm of understanding maybe
even interest frankly again because
people are bone weary they're working
they're not studying the nuances of
posturing in Central Europe and Eastern
Europe yet what's happening there's like
a train leaving a station it's headed
toward Texas City and a fatal moment
there have been a number of really great
books written about Texas City ones that
no doubt are I'll sound you know
sanctimonious and pious or no doubt or
better than this one they do things
better than I do in this book some are
very academic and very scientific and
help to really deconstruct again the
science the engineering of what happened
the physics of what happened with this
explosion there are some that are
incredibly acutely personal to the point
where they're they're told through the
eyes of one person what I wanted to do
was a mixture of
both of those and much like those trains
leaving the station to keep extending my
analogy here is to find a number of
individuals in Texas City who perhaps
were emblematic of the city at large and
I'll tell you what that was a really
really hard thing to do I about this
extensively again with my faithful and
extremely talented research partners so
many people died so many people were
injured so many people were left
homeless that at the outset of our story
or our investigation into the story
examination of the story we had to I
suppose leave people at the side of the
road at that station again sorry but we
that was a really tough task we had to
basically recreate people's lives and
then perhaps decide at some point they
weren't a central enough figure in the
story to be emblematic of the story at
large that was an awful awful a decision
we just had to say some people would fit
into what we want to do and some people
wouldn't it was a simple but as complex
as that and that was an awful awful
process that I think a wide know lasted
for months months on end
and sitting you know alone as so many
decades removed from this disaster and
geographically removed it was a pretty
humbling process at the end of the day
and I think in at least in some small
fashion we keyed in on some folks who
might think you had to write about to
tell the Texas City story the mayor of
the city who much I guess like Rudy
Giuliani became a heroic figure for some
he was at the heart of this story and a
really wonderful amazing man who has a
wonderful amazing family very generous
family a guy who had returned home from
World War two only had a
a twelfth grade education but was
probably you know one of the smartest
people and I've ever met he had been
gravely injured in the Battle of the
Bulge during World War two
and somehow rather almost like a figure
in it you know an old Jimmy Stewart
movie found himself the mayor of the
small town they don't seem to happened
by accident and then not too long after
being mayor
he gets confronted with you know hell on
earth a nightmare of unbelievable
proportions and in a lot of ways to me
much like hundreds and thousands of
people there he embodied you know that
the true rising and and yes positive
elements of this story the most unlikely
person perhaps the most quiet and
ordinary an average American found
himself reaching down for into a well of
courage that even he didn't know was
there and behaving in extraordinary ways
and helpful ways kind ways generous ways
and as the mayor the town he embodied
when hundreds of people there did it's a
it's a it's a story that should almost
be studied in a way for for the way a
community behaves almost the sociology
of it I didn't really kind of tackle the
story in that literal way but I hope
some of that comes across we tried to
look at what was going on in different
portions of the community different
different economic strata different ages
and and that was deliberate just to give
you a cross-section but to show at the
end of the day the uniformity people
without knowing it we're moving in
concert and they were moving in concert
to help each other it you know when
you're a journalist and as I've been for
him too long you you get very very
cynical and the the great joy of working
on the story was it that I could I could
feel the cynicism peeling away and it's
something that yeah I think affected me
personally in some ways
I knew that to be true because I
actually dragged my daughter down to
Texas City with me one day I attended
one of the annual memorial services that
they have there in Texas City which is
an incredibly moving event that begins
with the ringing of a bell by the fire
chief in the town and it kind of just
peels out and kind of blossoms over the
community and this flat stretch of land
that kind of gives way to the Gulf of
Mexico eventually and Galveston Bay and
each tone is for another fallen fireman
and it just goes on and on forever and
it's sad
I felt good in some ways about the fact
that I had taken my daughter down there
I don't know that I can't honestly say
she absorbed it all or understood why we
were there but I thought it's just sort
of important that by osmosis or just
proximity to the folks there to the
people there the survivors there that
she be in the presence of people who
acted courageously and bravely and and
extra bravely more bravely because they
did it anonymously they did it in a time
period when you know it was this pre
media age and the opportunity is to toot
your horn and go in front of the camera
and in some ways you know draw attention
to yourself they just didn't exist if
they did the people there wouldn't
succumb to that anyway so it was an
amazing experience to work on it
even in terms of a sort of a process of
self understanding if I may say so one
thing that I just kind of came to that
that really jarred me and it had a lot
to do with 9/11 as well in terms of
parallels is the fact that you know
during 9/11 we I think you know we gotta
kind of got inured to the the little
thing that would scroll across the
bottom of our screens or watching The
Evening News and it would
a you know 1,000 and the number always
seem to rise you know and and then you
identified dad the presumption or the
assumption being that they were
unidentified dead and as we know of
course you know there were countless
people missing in in 911 the same thing
happened here the number wasn't as high
but there are dozens and dozens and
dozens and dozens of missing people in
Texas City people who vanished from
earth from their families from their
loved ones in the blink of an eye to
honor those people the citizens of Texas
City decided that they would you know
build a Memorial Cemetery and it's a
very moving place if you go there today
there are simple stone markers and a
little patch of land to the north of the
city and they're just marked with
numbers because we don't know who's
buried there and it's it's an incredibly
powerful a place just to you know walk
in and kind of recreate or remember what
I came to learn and what some people
there quietly shared with us was the
fact that in those graves where the
remains of the deceased the unidentified
remains were laid to rest it's a pretty
good bet that in some of those caskets
are laid to rest the remains of black
white and Hispanic residents of the area
in other words they're a commingled
because they couldn't be identified as a
whole body as a whole person and when it
came time when the decision was made
finally to lay these poor souls to rest
Shirley and I please apologize I
apologize to you for being so graphic
pieces body parts were assembled and put
together and surely pieces of a black
person were laid to rest with pieces of
a Caucasian and Hispanic that fact
and it's occurrence the way that it
occurred the kind of quiet and dignified
way that it occurred unleashed a whole
new kind of avenue of exploration and
way of thinking about what happened in
Texas City 1947 deep not just in the
heart of Texas in the heart of the south
and how for a minute or two or three
racism as people knew it then ceased to
exist and the races came together in a
way that they never wanted to but that
they surely did and in a way that would
forever change people there's some
evidence to indicate that the city was
divided and not unlike cities across
America segregation still existed there
was no room for segregation at the
Memorial Cemetery when people were laid
to rest it was a very literal and you
know provocative and I suppose it could
have been controversial but it just
simply wasn't the people there deemed it
to not be controversial and they buried
their dead together they celebrated the
memories of those people together they
mourned the loss their losses together
you know almost metaphorically speaking
we began reading story after story and
and talking to folks over and over again
who had talked how about how at the very
instant after the disaster many of them
thought it was Judgment Day that that
God had perhaps was seeking retribution
or just calling people home along with
that thought what physically happened to
a lot of people is that when the
explosion occurred people were were
singed their white skin was turned brown
or black
they were coated with thick tar and oil
there was even a molasses factory in in
Texas City that exploded coated people
with molasses family members would
encounter other family members in
presume them to be
a different race than what they had been
and that's something unnerving
extraordinary and humbling had occurred
that perhaps God had turned their own
relatives into a different color someone
who had been white had been turned into
a black man and vice versa the buildings
back then were filled with asbestos and
some black residents of Texas City were
coated white with asbestos and relatives
tried to grapple with that the confusion
the hysteria the smoke the fire of the
not knowing white residents who were
affected physically that way were
admitted to what were then called the
colored wards of of area hospitals the
segregated areas where were
african-american residents were treated
and there they would stay for days and
even weeks on end until some family
members began to realize that there was
a possibility that someone might think
that their their relative in fact was
african-american instead of white and so
amazing stories of people getting
together and and in a way you know
confronting things that that had been
codified and had existed obviously in
America for for decades and decades and
decades and it changed it changed people
in profound obvious physical ways
spiritual ways of right right in their
their soul and culminated again and at
that moment when people were laid to
rest together at that memorial service
for those folks it was a
multi-denominational multiracial event
also frankly I think unheard of in the
south and you had Catholic priest rabbi
Pisgah Paley and on and on and to to say
their prayers and lay folks to rest so
even on a
another level to me the story was it was
extraordinary that act and in just the
courage almost the unspoken communal
decision that that's the way it should
be this disaster was too profound for us
to continue to be separated and it
caused people to get together in again
in ways that they never they never
thought if you don't mind so I'll see
some babbling in my meandering way I'll
just read something again real quickly
let me since I just talked about that
event let me let me skip ahead I guess
to to the to the day that the city
decided to bury its unidentified dead
finally a two acre plot of land has
found a mile and a half to the north of
the city limits and a pasture where thin
strands of grass bend in the wind and
the soil is less spongy it is a good
distance from the waterfront and if one
stands in the center of that piece of
earth the docks and piers would seem to
be a thousand miles away it is peaceful
only a curving lane passes alongside it
and it feels like a place where solitude
will be permanent Deramus who's an
Episcopalian a leader in the community
calls several clergymen and asks them to
participate in the dedication of the new
Texas City Memorial Cemetery on the
third Sunday of June a rabbi from
Galveston will be there and Deramus
still shaken from being denied land to
bury black people make sure to invite
Reverend FM Johnson the leading black
minister in Texas City with the land
finally secured preparations are made to
receive the dead up until three days ago
there have still been frantic efforts to
identify the remains in Camp Wallace FBI
fingerprint experts pored over any clues
one last time but now time is up
beginning Saturday at 8 p.m. a 10-man
crew at Camp Wallace had begun preparing
the remains after they are removed from
the refrigerated coolers the remains of
each of the 60
unidentified or wrapped in a wide burial
cloth a piece of white ducting holds the
cloth intact in with a crayon the number
assigned to the nameless dead is written
on the ducting the bundles are lowered
into identical silk-lined Cypress
coffins none of the bodies is intact
none fills the 6-foot 3 inch long
caskets each casket has a number on it
the same kinds of numbers that have been
put on those police traffic tags and
affixed to the bodies in the Texas City
High School gym the camp the camp
Wallace crew works through the night in
the morning a Houston mortician has
arrived with 51 hearses funeral homes
around Texas have donated sprays of
flowers the caskets are loaded onto the
hearses
and the two mile-long caravan begins its
long trip to the north side of Texas
City at 8:45 on Sunday morning June 22nd
the immensity of the moment is
incalculable
some will say nothing remotely like it
has ever occurred in the southern half
of the United States a mass burial for
blacks and whites who had lived in the
most thoroughly segregated ways possible
unspoken is the pervasive belief that
limbs and organs from several different
people have somehow been placed together
in some of the caskets the black and
white and Hispanic residents of Texas
City are literally being buried together
and now the 63 nameless are being sent
to their final reward after weeks of
waiting and refrigerated sterile limbo
and they're being dispatched under the
mutual guidance of an Episcopalian a
Methodist a white Baptist a black
Baptist a Jew and a Catholic it is muggy
the heat is seemingly swaying along the
ground moving hot and moist among the
crowd elderly women and veils are being
held under the arm and their children
are flipping paper fans in front of
their sweating faces the clouds look
leaden about to burst the lone airplane
is arcing overhead the waterfront is far
to the west but there is such a
stillness that it seems as if there is a
ship's sea horn sounding from Galveston
Bay a preacher moves through the crowd
pressing a copy of the New Testament
into every hand thousands of copies had
just arrived from some businessman in
Philadelphia Mayor Curtis train has come
and he takes his place alongside the
other 2,000 mourners it may be that
everyone who is now
permanently fled from Texas City and is
healthy enough to venture from a sickbed
has assembled on the patches of toasted
grass the seven clergymen take their
places on a green felt covered platform
erected in front of a row of blood red
carnations alongside the platform
there's a spray of pink flowers shaped
into a ship's anchor and placed there by
some old sailors we'd pooled with money
they had left there are small trucks at
the edge of the soggy feel waiting to
move the damp black dirt across the
simple caskets beginning with nameless
dead number 243
each casket is carried by four men honor
guard of longshoreman fireman in World
War two veterans black men white men and
Hispanic men all reaching for the coffin
handles Curtis watches as the 63 caskets
are placed over six huge trenches ready
to be lowered into the ground every of
the 45 minutes ceremony this is not the
way he and father bill watched Roach had
wanted segregation to end but maybe
father Roach knew that this was the only
way it could ever happen the first to
speak is rabbi Louis Fagan from
Galveston his prayers crackling out from
the speaker's placed on top of the sound
trucks each of the seven clergymen reads
a short holy passage wherever an FM
Johnson the Negro preacher stares out
over his first impromptu congregation of
white brown and black mourners he
addressed wrestled all night with his
choice trying to find something that
would suggest there were painful lessons
in the Texas City disaster he had
finally decided to read the ninetieth
psalm some people might be bound to hate
him bound to hate the black man
selection because it suggested Texas
City was being punished by a vengeful
God thou Carius them away is with the
flood they are as asleep in the morning
there like grass which groweth up we are
consumed by thine anger and by thy wrath
are we troubled thou has set our
iniquities before the our secret sins in
the light of thy countenance who knoweth
the power of thine anger so teach us to
number our days that we may apply our
hearts unto wisdom finally Frank Deramus
steps to the microphone he reads from
the Book of Common Prayer and then he
recites the Lord's Prayer
when he finishes the entire crowd
murmurs that response our Father who art
in heaven the voices of the 2,000
mourners sound someone says like the
insistent aching roll of the surf along
the Gulf of Mexico Deramus nods to the
casket bearers and using ropes they
lower the coffins into the shallow
trenches an old man and his son are
sinking to their knees alongside one
trench clasping their hands closing
their eyes and heaving with tears a
middle-aged black woman her face puffy
with grief is stepping forward and
clutching a handful of wilted White
Oleander blossoms she stands over one
particular casket slowly releases the
blossoms and watches as each curling
flower petal flutters down the tractor
drivers and dirt movers watch from the
edge of the ceremony one by one they
flick their cigarettes into the field
start their engines each of the trenches
will be covered sixty-three small
granite stones will be placed in neat
rows over the graves there's nothing
other stones other than the number each
of these remains has been assigned the
numbers run randomly from one five two
to four zero four if anybody has any
questions or thoughts now Texas City I'd
be glad to
sure I haven't read the book and for
people who are not sure oh you're with
this story you left us we were on on the
dock with the freighter with ammonium
nitrate in it on fire
what made it this catastrophe sure yeah
well you know took the whole city
spoken like a good editor you know in in
essence a ship blew up in in Texas City
it was an ocean-going freighter and it's
called the grande Kampf it was it was a
Liberty ship that had once served the
United States kind of as a pickup truck
of the ocean during World War two it
criss crossed the oceans delivering
troops and supplies to aid in the war
the war effort it was a Liberty Ship and
it's a great vessel if you're into
maritime history is a real sturdy vessel
that that helped us win the war after
the war these kinds of ships were
decommissioned put in mothballs all
around the country to begin the effort
to win the Cold War we decided the
United States did to give some of these
ships to our allies including in this
instance to France
France was going to employ the ship to
come to the United States to get
something else from us that being
ammonium nitrate to help see those
fields in Europe and that's you know
where the disaster disaster really began
coalescing in earnest with the orders in
aid of our military and White House
officials arrangements were made for
thousands and thousands of hundred pound
bags of ammonium nitrate to be loaded
onto the ground comp in Texas City and
then be sent overseas there's actually
you know kind of like life itself
there's always an eternal mystery at the
core there's a great deal of debate as
to exactly what sparked the disaster the
physical the physics of it and what
exactly caused the explosion and there's
a lot of debate some people say it was
the simple act of someone smoking a
cigarette and throwing it on to a bag
some people have suggested that these
bags in fact we're even delivered to
Texas City already on fire and that it
took a unique set of circumstances to to
really fan those flames there are some
people who even suggest that
ammonium nitrate being so brilliant and
devious in a brilliant way that it
spontaneously combusted and took on a
life of its own my faithful great
researcher Mike had I think I'd say the
good fortune and maybe the honor of
talking to you know one of the sailors
who was a longshoreman excuse me who was
at Ground Zero to use that that term and
the way he described the flames that he
was seeing coming up from the belly of
the ship in the lower holes it really
seemed alive you've heard that it's an
old song of the fire seemed alive
sailors and longshoremen were aware that
there was something on fire in the in
the the belly of the ship a low deck and
hold number four and they began
clamoring down puffs of smoke were
coming out they took down a water jug a
simple little water jug and doused a
little flame way over on the other side
of the ship
that flame reappeared same size same
eerie color went over there he poured
water on it it went out and then popped
up over here and it seemed to be alive
that long shoreman being a also a
veteran of a lot of danger and adventure
during World War two and also being very
intuitive knew that something bad
something really really bad was about to
happen and he got the hell out of there
and basically ran away as fast as he
could and then came back like a lot of
people to help people after the disaster
the ship blew up and it set in motion a
series of other disasters the ship
disintegrated it was obliterated the
anchor the
the multi-ton anchor when sailing for a
mile and a half through the sky pieces
of the deck you know went flying
everywhere
windows were rattled 100 miles away
people dropped to their knees in
Galveston in Denver Colorado which is a
far piece from Texas City a geologist
was walking by his graphs in his
seismographs and taking a casual look at
his graphs at the exact moment the
disaster occurred and his graph began
lurching in an extremely agitated
fashion he ran some quick calculations
estimation is trying to figure out where
it was coming from in his his knowledge
of science suggested that something bad
really bad was happening in in Texas
maybe in Southeast Texas and maybe even
an atomic bomb the first suggestion from
a lot of observers was that an atomic
bomb had been dropped there was
something tantamount to a mushroom cloud
that that enveloped the whole city the
finest war correspondents of the day
people who had survived and reported
admirably and bravely in world war ii
were dispatched to the area by the New
York Times by The Associated Press and
what they did when they reported back to
their superiors was that this a1 AP
reporter literally said this this was a
greater scene of devastation than what I
saw in Japan after the the atomic bomb
was dropped there it looked that bad it
had no formal recognition at least along
the waterfront to anything that anybody
could remember so I hope I answered your
question it was a very good question I
should have started with an answer
absolutely a chain reaction yeah no
absolutely and I was just about to get
to that before I veered off again it got
set in motion fires other secondary
explosions another freighter
packed with ammonium nitrate essentially
you know a day later blew up it was a
greater explosion than that initial
explosion a smaller loss of life so many
people had been killed there were fewer
people to kill again to be so graphic
people had fled the second explosion was
in fact Raider yeah refineries burst
open one after another and you know
imagine the fear of people who really
had lost the ability to escape to get
away communication was down another can
point of convergence that day in fact in
the weeks building to that day and then
that day there was a phone strike people
couldn't use the phone they couldn't
call each other the phone lines that
were working were not manned initially
another conversion so yes I'm sorry
there were enormous
you know fires that welled up for four
days on end it brought in fire
departments from around Texas even
around the country relief efforts from
around the country triage units
President Truman ordered that the hero
the World War two hero of the Bataan
Death March general Jonathan Wainwright
be dispatched with the fourth army to
occupy the town and essentially you know
cordon it off and retain control it was
a massive massive relief effort in
response to a massive you know a set of
conflagrations fires awful moments so
yeah Charlie
speaking as a reporter and as a
researcher what was and I haven't gotten
to the end of the book yet as far as you
know who your primary sources working
was still alive
sure tell us about your breakthrough
interviews the archival material that
really kind of shown the way to the rest
of the material well you read the story
really came together when you have that
a-ha moment as a journey yes yeah you
know probably the best answer is taking
a look and it's sounds like insider
baseball but it was really studying what
other people had written at that time
the real nitty gritty on the ground you
know correspondence whether it be radio
which is your area of expertise John or
the news dispatches that they were
filing written versions that they were
then you know having copy boys race up
to the newspapers in Houston and
elsewhere those first-hand accounts
I think form the framework what I think
we decided it was important my research
team and I decided it was to really also
go a little bit off the meter and take a
look at what some people might consider
a non mainstream journalism we found an
enormous ly rich repository of material
in the african-american newspapers of
the day that told an incredibly rich
story that I think hadn't been widely
told about the impact primarily in the
african-american community in Texas City
and that blossomed and led to a lot of
of questions and thoughts and an edit
and you know dimensions of the story
that was a I guess yeah that nerve you
know Theravada aha experience in some
way and a pleasant one because it led us
to meet people that we hadn't known
about you know the interesting thing
about the Texas cities story it was kind
of cliche slogan these days six degrees
of separation it's interesting to me
living in Texas now for quite a while
that if you
work at it a little bit during the
course of any day you'll find someone
through dint of conversation and even
happenstance a convergence yet again
you'll find someone who's got a
connection at Texas City it happened the
instant I walked in the door
here this evening and met someone
affiliated with this great bookstore who
said by the way my dad was a doctor and
my mom was a nurse there in Houston and
you know they stared right into the face
of the tragedy in their way because
suddenly they were doing you know
incredible work to save people that were
being rushed up to Houston to be treated
so I had only walked in the door within
five seconds and had met encountered
another connection so I guess you know
in a lot of ways were an accumulation of
aha moments and I'm not sure I answer
that but
I'm really excited about the possibility
of reading this book as I was listening
to your talking I was wondering can you
describe the layout of the town in
comparison to where the ship was
described by how close the school was
that was overcrowded the hospitals that
sort of thing and how the explosion
affected the surrounding area yeah yeah
what's what's you know 1947 things you
know less was known about the dangers of
the kinds of things that we can create
and you know whether it be from an
environmental perspective or even just a
pure explosive capacity we just didn't
know as much as we do today I'm stating
the obvious
so ringing the waterfront of Texas City
it's a you know it's a town that's in
between for those who don't know it's in
between Galveston and Houston you might
know it as a place that you kind of pass
by if you haven't been there and turn
off the highway the Gulf Freeway that
stretches from Houston to Galveston
you kind of have to work a little bit to
get to it you have to turn left as your
head south and get to it and if you go
as far as you can go after you you kind
of turn east you'll come to the Texas
City waterfront and it's really you know
an extraordinary thing to see it's just
ringed by miles of refineries and
petrochemical plants there are more
today than there were then but in in
essence that that kind of layout existed
so what you have as sort of a point of
contact if you sailed into Texas City
like the the sailors who are on this
doomed ship the ground calm
what you'd see first were the refineries
and the chemical plants there was
Monsanto it was probably the biggest
presence in the the corporation that was
affected the most in terms of loss of
life and in in commercial property
that's sort of the baseline of Texas
City it's the reason maybe it's there is
this petrochemical and refinery area and
the reason I mentioned that we you know
we've learned a lot in this day and age
back here in 1947 there were folks who
lived way too close to there a lot of it
was flattened out kind of empty field
that that was crisscross buy oyster
shell pave roads they would dredge up
oyster shells and kind of hammer them
down and you'd have this sort of
bleached bone white oyster shell network
of roads some of the most informal roads
you have refineries the sort of little
patchwork of of roads and then homes if
I had to say you know ten blocks away
an average city block of ten blocks away
there were was the beginning of the
residential community and primarily as a
point of contact again the Hispanic
community and the black community were a
little bit closer that's and then there
was a you know in in in in earnestly
Crossing Texas Avenue in one of the
major arteries in the town you would
find the in the beginning of the the
white community for lack of a better
term so all in all homes way too close
and final estimation and final study
almost everyone agrees that homes were
placed too close to the waterfront
schools City Hall all that kind of
anchor points of a community way too
close
10 20 30 blocks away
that might actually seem like a great
distance it wasn't for an explosion is
powerful so they were sprinkled and all
around
boom town again not a wealth of medical
facilities certainly nothing on par to
handle this and I think you know one of
the final proofs of that I mentioned
this earlier in some of the stuff you
know when I ran it probably sounded out
of context but I mentioned the Texas
City High School gymnasium and the fact
that it was turned into a morgue there
were so many bodies so quickly in a
small town they didn't know what to do
and they decided quickly collectively
frankly almost you know miraculously
calmly to turn the Texas City High
School gymnasium into a temporary morgue
housing dozens and dozens of bodies
remains some incredible you know imagery
from there as it was relayed to us it
was springtime and people were preparing
for the prom kids were gonna graduate
and getting ready for the senior prom
and decorations and you know movement
was afoot to turn that the high school
gym old hardwood floor you know those
old style windows with kind of the kind
of metal meshing and in the window and
and then obviously the plans for the
prom are put aside in the whole
gymnasium is filled with bodies there's
a an amazing photograph that really you
know says it better than me you see some
weak light filtering in from outside and
you could tell it it's cutting through
probably some haze left by a fire by
something awful and it cuts through the
upper reaches of the high school gym
window and then the you know if you if
your eye trails down then you see the
basketball hoop and it looks maybe
innocence reclaimed it's basketball and
if your eye goes to the bottom of the
you know the frame of the photograph you
see neatly arranged body after body
covered with grey military-issue
blankets that were brought by the fourth
army and covering these remains and then
in the background you'll see children
Jers walking around trying to identify
their parents sisters brothers so forth
so I fear it again tonight I hope at the
early part of my answer answered your
your question yeah it was everything was
too close I was always Sunday
understanding that the ship that that
blew up was actually trying to get into
Alveston dog's history it and he was
trying to it was destined to go to
Galveston on its way out of Texas City
there was a sense that it could go there
and pick up some more supplies one thing
that's still a matter of debate the
answer your question real quickly what
is clear what's certainly no what
happened was that it was docked in
Houston prior to coming to Texas City
what didn't happen in Houston was it
being loaded with ammonium nitrate for
whatever reason and I tried to
investigate this port officials they're
deemed ammonium nitrate to be a
substance they didn't want on their dock
and again for whatever reasons it was
deemed that Texas City would handle it
and so it sailed down Galveston Bay and
docked in Texas City you you know you
mentioned again it's almost a
convergence and you know if not for fate
circumstance poetry whatever God's hand
none of this would have would have
happened the the crew was French crew
which had been sent to America to
reclaim this vessel and then to pick up
goods in America and bring it back to
France to help essentially really feed
their own children was really enroute
back home before it was ordered at the
last minute to go to Texas City the guys
on the vessel were writing letters that
day for that morning and the evening
before the explosion writing the letters
that would be their last letters to
their family and they're writing
that they were looking forward to coming
home after being away like old salts for
months on end at sea and they were
finally going to come home so there's a
lot of you know mystery about that
vessel even going back to the thought
that perhaps somewhere in the lower hold
that there might have been a fire and
that it came into port already on fire
in some way so question that of the the
majority of the people that were killed
one from the initial explosion of the
ship but rather than when Monsanto
chemical yeah yeah yeah you look if you
wanted to look at it as a percentage
that's exactly right yeah
people were killed in many many ways
they were just simply knocked dead by
the blast and we literally knocked dead
people were set on fire I mean I you
know miss any way imaginable and
Monsanto again had the you know the
great unfortunate being Romans death the
epicenter imagine there being a really
potent and you know very active a major
in you know importance really I suppose
you'd say a productive chemical plant
right across the street from the the
World Trade Center or at the base of the
World Trade Center in the lobby area if
you will like that's almost what
happened you could almost argue a
similarity that it was just too close it
was dozens of yards away a very short
distance from from where the ship blew
up and and the people who were at work
there you know were decimated yeah it's
a good question was this Monsanto
chemicals docks though also well they
had a an understanding it was actually
the docks there as they are today or are
owned by and kind of a quasi private
public you know entity the Texas City
terminal railway corporation and they
worked in conjunction with Montana
so there were certainly friends though
they weren't exactly you know it wasn't
exactly at the Monsanto dock oh sorry
I'm so sorry you had you both my parents
grew up in Texas City and I've met
several people who are probably the same
some people who were alive den when it
were children then when it happened and
so all my life I've you know heard the
stories from my parents my my mother
lost both of her parents her father was
the postmaster in fact but what I
remember always hearing was that the
huge loss of life were the spectators
who came to watch and and I don't know
I'm almost afraid afraid to ask this
question but there because I don't know
if it's an urban myth or but there was
always this hint or underlying you know
hint that there were a munitions guns on
this ship yeah and that there was were
some sort of you know purchase between
the another country in the United States
and I just wondered it in your research
if he found that you're right it wasn't
a myth that there was ammunition on
board the grand camp small arms
ammunition you know what it was doing
there and why it was enroute back to
France there's a greater debate about
that but it's indicated in a lot of the
manifests and inventories that did
survive the disaster so it was there
what it did in terms of its contribution
that's also another mystery I mean
people have debated it wasn't an
accelerator you not to go in any great
detail but you don't just you know get
ammonium nitrate and caught and wreak
havoc there has to be something that
accompanies it
and there there's a sense that that
didn't help
having ammunition on board but that the
greater sense is that that that that
fact it's not an urban method that fact
that there was ammunition on board
didn't caused and spark it but again it
didn't help an issue that seemed like no
one wanted to talk about it yeah well
you know there are a lot of things about
the Texas City disaster and yet I'm
hopelessly biased so please forgive me
but I think it's the subtitle I'm just
noticing says the Forgotten disaster and
I thought so long and hard you know
about that ye is and there are many many
many many things that that were laid to
rest and again I think a good portion of
it had to do with the fact that folks
there again they work they don't draw
attention they rebuild the city symbol
you know down there is the Phoenix it's
on different flags and city emblems and
it's about you know rising up rebuilding
the rising if you will and in and so you
know when you have that kind of
environment and spirit I think a lot of
the stories either disappear or kept
quiet and then go away when you
mentioned earlier about not knowing or
falling into this pit of not knowing
we're just torture because of all of the
people who were I mean everyone was
effect yeah I mean you knew someone who
was killed or murdered so I can see how
it would be hard to stop yeah with the
human interest part of it I was in
dinner I was in Houston on Friday and
met an old colleague of mine journalist
pal
I'm guessing I guess she's in her early
60s mid 60s and I sat next to her for
years and we'd go to lunch and I know
her and you know she was a friend and lo
and behold she told me that she was in
Danforth Elementary School which is the
incredibly decimated and devastated
elementary school where children fled
for their lives and some fell to their
knees praying praying to Jesus because
they thought it was Judgment Day as well
and she was one of them and and one of
those children they would survived and
it's you know yeah
and I think you know again probably
human nature at some ultimate level to
not talk about those things too much
I want to thank you really because my
brother is here and we've we have always
wondered why has no no one ever told
this story because it was huge
it was just huge and affected so many
people and I mean even you know my
generation I wasn't even born yet but
it's still such a huge factor in our
family's life so I really appreciate
your dude what was your you mentioned
your mom was she injured did she know
her sister was I asked a curious
question did she lose her hearing no but
she remembers the school crumbling
around her and people trying to get out
people being hurt trying to get out and
but her the fascinating memory of hers
was when she got outside she didn't know
where she was you know all the houses
were gone you know all the points of
reference were gone
yeah I stood upside down so so that was
just you know very fascinating and then
trying to find her way home
know that simple act you yeah no but
thank you thank you thanks for sharing
that story - I grew up in Texas City and
was 4 years old when the explosion
happened there you were know I'm sure oh
it's ok I could hear you yeah and why so
many people were killed is there was no
security hmm and they were all down
there five to six-hundred watching the
fire yeah with their children and
strollers and Families
yeah it's why do you if I may ask you a
question why wasn't there security
I don't they didn't have it yeah and I
think yeah I mean that's really the
conclusion I came to today it seems like
such an obvious we've got security at
the shopping mall there wasn't security
at the maid
or plants there was a whole nother you
know rabbit hole that I mentioned
earlier I really almost fell down and my
family was gonna have to you know file a
missing persons report cuz I was now
that never come back yeah that there was
no security at the and the schools and
the downtown was really probably closer
sure then I mean Danforth probably
wouldn't half-a-mile yeah Elementor sure
yeah it was very very close and so
downtown was just so within a mile yeah
what you're saying it is great because
it allows me to meander for a second
again if you if you'd indulge me one of
the things that I tried to write about
and that I thought I would write about
endlessly was the fact that at this time
period in America 1947 we had great
faith in the men in the white lab coats
they were considered wizards and we were
going to address polio we were going to
address cancer we were gonna we had won
the Great War there was a great sense of
this sort of [ __ ] Brio this muscular
sense that America can do everything and
take care of problems in in conjunction
with that there was just great faith
great faith in what the scientists were
doing scientists a lot of folks you know
believed had won World War two
it wasn't the GI Joe in the trenches
that it was actually the men in the the
white lab coats in their various
projects around the country at harnessed
nature's forces atomic energy and
created you know the weapons that we
needed to close the chapter in World War
two so you know you leave that episode
of time that historical context again
that great kind of geopolitical bit of
history a great sense of history and
technology and then you begin to see how
it began to trickle down to Texas City
such great faith suggests that maybe you
don't need
security what could go wrong the folks
who work there can corral it they'll
know what to do with it that we have
faith in them they help to win the war
you know this was an accident it wasn't
intentionally you know gender did it but
there remain a lot of questions about
why it happened and again as you
correctly pointed out you know why folks
could just literally walk with children
within yards of a ship that's filled
with the most deadly explosive imagine
one that was about to blow up
so I'm sorry I gave another speech I
think people were too trusting yeah yeah
it never occurred to you because even I
was born and raised here and I was nine
and a half and I remember it clearly
we felt the the earth easier in Austin
the rumbling in the shelter Earth Rumble
at all and the school kids we were given
hours off of class and we would we would
spend hours in our classrooms with
little boxes filling toilet articles and
stuff like that for the school kids left
in Texas City and it became known as the
Texas school kids disaster too you know
for the school kids so it was very real
- yeah - yeah to worry about because you
could hear even if there was a big fire
sure everybody went it was like
entertainment yeah that's a great word
doing trust there was just great trust
one of the wonderful things my my
research team did for me I asked them
help me understand the mood of the
nation let's take a look a little bit of
the historical context or some you know
great writers out there of narrative
nonfiction David marinus at the
Washington Post is just as brilliant at
doing this at drawing kind of a
historical backdrop the big picture
what's going on in the big picture set
against the
the more narrowly focused story and what
I wanted to know was what was going on
in the big picture so let's look at some
national publications let's talk to some
historians what was the mood of folks at
the at the time my researcher Mike Smith
came back to me one day with a number of
ads that he had pulled down from various
publications at the time and you can
learn a lot about where you are in in a
moment in history and geography I
suppose just by looking at advertising
you really learn volumes and what I
learned from from looking at what Mike
brought to the table was that there was
you know wild faith wild trust in
chemistry and science there were ads at
that time in 1947 advocating the
beneficial uses of asbestos and to the
point of almost suggest and get
ingesting it was beneficial there were
ads and you know we laugh at this now
that and you probably have seen these or
recall them or know about them that
suggested that you know using tobacco
smoking cigarettes wasn't just enjoyable
it was truly medically beneficial that
if he smoked it it would make you more
healthy than you were before healthier
than your neighbor smoked more and and
so and we know differently now but but
looking at those ads and it's not you
know we just know more now and it's not
to you know suggest that oh you know how
could they not people just didn't know
we just didn't know so know there was a
trust there was a faith here in Texas
yeah we were still even though we had
participated in the war we were still
pretty much isolated I mean it was a
huge state it took four hours to drive
from here to San Antonio on a little too
late enjoy you know so you can imagine
people didn't just get in a plane and
fly or you didn't have TV you depended
on the radio and word of mouth so these
are good so you just simply go we're
eating right yeah thank you Bill thanks
for doing this I grew up in Texas City
area
and it's not born when this happened but
obviously throughout my entire childhood
the interesting thing about a couple of
things people have mentioned today and
talk about the Forgotten yeah I promise
that was the case
we rarely really have there were there
were annual of course observances there
was there were there was nothing of a
large scale significant observances in
fact the Memorial Park that you
referenced out on loop 197 was in very
very bad disarray until about 15 maybe
20 years ago when it is now was done was
done right the god interrupts you a kiss
and you know perpetually curious but why
me why why I why did people I honestly
believe that the reason is because it's
a petrochemical city or and people
wanted to not I wanted to forget that
that happened because that was the
livelihood for 85 90 percent of the town
and you know all through school I worked
in those refineries and the last thing I
wanted to do was to think about what
could happen and so was it out of fear
of you know something punitive happening
you're out of the workplace or just
because it seemed like you cast
aspersion on the place where you were
proud to work and it was your lively I
don't know I think it was more of let's
don't think about that let's don't think
that that could happen again and it was
more of out of sight out of mind
that was then but even you know the town
was 15,000 then it got up to about forty
to forty thousand sure in the late
sixties early seventies where it has
remained right uh but its population
wise it's remained about that because
people are moving farther out and sure
coming back into work but at any rate by
way of reference the lady asked about
the location picture Lamar Boulevard
here being ninth Avenue which is the
main artery going into town and the
plants being downtown Austin that's how
close it is how close it was that's very
good and at any rate I really appreciate
you doing this there there have been of
course historical references before one
was more of a pictorial but sure yeah
there's another good photo but um
Barriss to say truthfully this probably
says it best
I live there for whatever 20-something
years as a kid and I will probably get
more out of this book I probably know as
much about it that would fit in a
thimble compared to what you found out
that's like my dad grew you know went to
high school occur when in Galveston of
course where all the windows are bright
- sure what happened but so here I
really appreciate themselves it sounds
like it's in your roots there yeah you
know I did to interrupt you and sorry to
head you off to something that you said
it made me think of an important part of
what happened in Texas City there was
another form of courage that emerged
over time the sense that it was okay to
question your elected officials really
you know turn the wayback machine 2 1947
really isn't too long ago you know we're
so accustomed now to registering our
complaints in court you know on the
airwaves in letters through emails now
what have you in protest not a lot of
that was done you know in 1947 what
people in Texas City you know slowly
came to think very very quietly in in a
really frustrating painful bittersweet
way as they sought answers not
compensation or relief or you know
monetary reward they just wanted to
answer some some form of resolution and
they began coming very quietly but
collectively to the sense that somebody
in charge had let this happen that
elected officials somebody who lived
above the cloud line he probably didn't
live in Texas City had set in motion
something that caused this to happen
that somebody was negligent and over
time that that sense that frustration
lack of answers really welled up in what
people hear these are veterans these are
patriots these are quiet ordinary you
know Americans and Aggies patriot and a
good you know lowercase D Democratic you
know way these are folks who were just
honest hard-working people and it hadn't
ever
occurred to them before to lodge
protests to frankly question the people
that they had voted for it put in office
and then they began doing just that and
it took a form of individual courage
that collective courage to begin
reexamining you know maybe what they
thought were some of the root causes of
this those big forces they wanted to
climb up the ladder and look above the
cloud line and see if they could
identify some folks some people that had
something to do with this and maybe even
yes at the end of the day were negligent
that were responsible for death and
destruction in Texas City
I took an amazing amount of courage
consider the historical context two
years after World War two you're a world
war two veteran or you've worked in a
defense plant you've laid down your life
for your country and now you're coming
to an awful realization alone and then
you know very quietly with your
neighbors that an elected official maybe
somebody who had voted for and put in
office in our democracy had had done
wrong by you in 1947 after we had won
the great war after they were in the
middle of this great sense of patriotism
and the sense even that living in Texas
City was the greatest place on earth
because now you're gonna help win this
the second war and you were gonna feed
people and you were going to keep them
away from the sway of communism so
people began questioning and ultimately
what resulted is is something that's in
the latter portion of my book it might
strike some people as some sort of
strange interruption in the story but
it's really the the concluding and
really ultimately giant bittersweet
phase of the story city the Texas City
and the people who live there began
entering into the courtroom and what
they began doing for one of the first
times in American history and this is so
I think courageous and important
they began suggesting that a legal
doctrine that it existed in the United
States since our founding that the King
can do no wrong ie officials at the
highest level of government can really
do no
wrong they can't be held accountable
through a civil action in the way that
we could hold our neighbors accountable
that in fact the king can do wrong that
in fact as much as we'd like to believe
that our leaders have our best interests
at heart and know what they're doing
that at times they've been negligent in
their duties to us in the context of
American history in the context of where
they are in Texas City it's an amazing
form of bravery collectively
they coalesced around a class-action
lawsuit it's centered around a widow
from Galveston who had lost her husband
in in the Texas City disaster it went to
federal court in Houston where they
actually won where the federal judge
ruled that that folks there had been
harmed by the federal government it was
rejected at the peels Court in New
Orleans went up to the Supreme Court
ultimately rejected there and after many
many years
the government very very very very
quietly did something through
legislation to indicate that yes we did
wrong by the people in Texas City
another interesting display of courage
in that community I'm getting a an
indication that I need to shave or that
that I'd better leave so thank you very
much for having me and I'd be glad to
expand bail minute Aglio is also author
of first son George W Bush and the Bush
family dynasty city on fire The
Forgotten disaster that devastated a
town and ignited a landmark legal battle
is published by HarperCollins on the web
at HarperCollins com